Hello everyone, my name is Steve Gilbert and this is chapter one in your course reader on C++ mechanics.
In today's lecture we're going to talk about how do you actually create a C++ program?
What are the mechanical steps you need to go through?
Now in 1970, when Ken Thompson and Dennis Ritchie created Unix,
Dennis Ritchie and Brian Curnahan also wrote a book to introduce the world to the C programming language.
In the book they wrote this, "The only way to learn a new programming language is to write programs for it.
The first program to write is the same for all languages. Print the words 'Hello World'."
Now you've probably heard of this, a Hello World program. This is where this statement comes from.
Now to go on to write. This is a big hurdle. To leap over it you have to be able to create the program text somewhere.
Compile it, load it, run it, and find out where your output went.
That's what we're going to cover today.
He goes on to say, I think a little tongue in cheek,
"With these mechanical details mastered, everything else is comparatively easy."
Now that's not exactly true. All of these mechanical details are necessary,
but they're not going to be sufficient for you to write good C++ programs.
But it is important that you learn how to do them and make them so they're second nature.
So we're going to start. Here's Dennis Ritchie's C version of Hello World.
We're going to create a C++ version and take our inspiration from the movie The Princess Bride.
"Hello, my name is Inigo Montoya. You killed my father. Prepare to die."
So we're not simply going to write one line. We're going to write one, two, three, four, five lines to output.
So how do we do that?
Well first, what we need to do is we need to write the C++ instruction somewhere.
This is called source code.
Now if you look at my little illustration on the right of this slide, you'll see that it says C code.
But it could be C code or C++ code or any kind of code.
So the basic idea behind a high-level language is that we write source code in high-level or human-like languages.
And then we take those languages and we convert them into a language the computer understands,
a mechanical or binary language.
Now for C++, we're going to write our code using the extension .cpp.
This is not really required for C++ like it is for Java with the .java extension.
But we're going to follow this convention, .cpp for C++ files, .c for C language files, .h for header files.
Now to convert our code, we need to use what's called a driver program.
Now frequently this will be called a compiler.
It's not actually a compiler.
It's a series of programs.
And we have one program that kind of orchestrates that.
And each of these different compilers or drivers have a series of programs that they work with.
And that series of programs we call a tool chain.
So Clang is one tool chain.
GCC is another tool chain.
Visual C++ is another tool chain.
And their driver programs are named similarly.
So Clang++ is the driver for the Clang tool chain, the one that's native to Mac OS.
C++ is the native driver for the GCC tool chain, the GNU compiler collection.
Cl is the driver for the Visual C++ compiler.
So what this driver does is it starts up these different programs.
The first program it starts is called the preprocessor.
What the preprocessor does is it reads through your source code and it replaces certain statements.
These are called preprocessor directives with the code that it intends to make a change to.
Mostly that's including header files in C++ and C and expanding macros.
Now when that's done, the preprocessed source code, what we call a translation unit,
can either be saved to disk, if you see in the picture over there,
those are usually saved in a file called a .i file or a .ii, standing for intermediate code,
or it can just be saved in memory, which is the normal case.
It's just stored in memory.
And then that output, the preprocessor output, is passed on to the next step,
which is called the compiler proper.
Again, most of us informally call Clang or GCC the compiler,
but again it's a driver that drives these different subprograms.
Now the compiler actually has two phases.
Sometimes it's called C1 and C2, and those are actually different programs.
The first part of the compiler is to parse the code, to make sense of your source code.
Is it formed correctly?
It finds syntax errors, like errors where you've made a typo, you forgot a comma,
you've made a mistake in the grammar.
It finds declaration errors, you've used names in your code
and you haven't told the compiler what they mean.
And it finds type errors.
You may perhaps write a code that's syntactically correct,
but you're trying to put the wrong kind of value in the wrong kind of variable.
All of those are discovered before we can actually generate any code.
This is the parsing phase, or phase one, of the compiler.
The second phase of the compiler is to take the output,
it's usually called a syntax tree or a parsing tree,
take the output of this first phase and pass it through a code generator.
And the code generator produces some kind of intermediate language.
On the tool chain we're going to be using, GCC, it produces assembly language.
On other tool chains, I believe Plang, it may produce some kind of intermediate code
that is closer perhaps to Java's byte code.
But it produces some kind of intermediate code,
not code that the computer can actually run.
And, again, if you look at the picture on the right,
you'll see that that code can be saved in a file,
a .asm file for assembly or a .s file, which is what GCC uses.
Now, once we've produced a human-readable form of the machine language
that the compiler understands,
we actually have to turn that into machine language.
And that's the assembly phase.
It uses something called the assembler.
And this produces an output that is pure binary code.
It is no longer human-readable.
It doesn't use the symbols that we use for reading and writing.
So the assembler takes this assembly language
and it produces native machine code.
And, again, depending on your tool chain,
if you're using Microsoft's CL tool chain, it will produce a .obj file.
For both Clang and G++, it produces a .o file.
Again, as the picture shows,
we can actually skip saving those intermediate files
and go directly from memory to memory again.
Now, the last part is something that you aren't familiar with in Java.
This is called linking.
So in Java, this happens when you run your program.
When you run your program, the linking happens at run time.
In C++, we do it before that.
We do it when we build our code.
And this whole process, the picture on the right,
is called building your executable,
turning your source code into an executable program.
Now, your object code can actually be understood by the CPU on your computer.
It is native object code.
However, to get it into memory, we have to load it.
And to load it, we're going to need some startup code to be combined with it.
So the linker combines that startup code with your object code
plus any kind of library features that you have used.
So it links those library features, those library functions,
those library classes, those library objects into your executable.
So it becomes part of your executable along with your object code.
As I mentioned, Java does the same thing,
but it does it when your program runs.
When you type in Java, it actually looks out on disk,
finds the library code, combines it in memory,
and produces the executable thing that runs.
Now, with the executable machine code,
you run it by running it on your computer.
Now, this is a little different than Java.
In Java, we run a hypervisor or a virtual machine, the program Java,
the Java virtual machine.
In C++, we do not.
The operating system actually loads your native machine code into memory,
and it's run by the CPU on your computer.
So that's the process.
Let's go ahead and look at each of those steps.
Now, in fact, as we go on in the semester,
we will kind of ignore each of these steps.
But it's important when you start out to realize that each of these things
is happening.
It will be important later when you write code,
because the compiler will give you error messages that give you a hint about
which part of the process failed.
Okay, so the simplest C++ program has one function named main.
Now, you're probably familiar with that with Java, public static void main.
It follows the same purpose.
So in Java, you have a function called main.
In C++, you have a function called main.
The syntax for the main function, again, is the entry point.
It's called by the startup code when you load your program.
That startup code was added by the linker, as we saw in the last slide,
to initialize the memory in your computer, set aside space,
set up the machine registers correctly,
and just then turn everything over to the CPU so it can start working.
Now, in your homework, you're going to find out that we are not going to have
a main function.
That's because I've put the main function inside a library,
and it's going to call a second function called run.
But I just don't want you to be confused when you start working your homework
and see that there is no main function.
There actually is a main function.
So let's create our main function here.
Let's look at the syntax for it.
So the first part is going to be these words main.
So that's probably simpler, you notice.
It doesn't say public static void.
It's just the main.
What this means is this tells us what the function returns.
That tells us the output.
So the kind of value produced by the function is the int.
The name of the function is main.
If we were to spell it with a capital M, it would still compile,
but the linker wouldn't find it when it tried to call it
because the linker is calling this main with lowercase.
So the functions are case sensitive.
Thirdly, if we passed any arguments, if we had any information we wanted to pass
in the main, we would pass any arguments inside this,
what's called a parameter list or argument list.
Here we don't have any, and so we don't need it.
The implementation, so this is called the interface of the function,
the part that tells the compiler what kinds of things go into the function,
what the name of the function is,
and what kind of things go out of the function.
The implementation is where the code is actually generated.
This is put between a set of braces, which mean the same thing they do in Java.
It means begin this section of code and end this section of code.
Another name for these set of braces is a block.
So a function body or the implementation is a block.
So let's look back at our code here.
And here is our block.
Let's look at how we would compile that.
I'm going to start just by compiling it with G++.
I'm going to say G++ hello.cpp.
If I don't get any errors, that means it worked correctly.
So this compiles and runs correctly.
In Unix, this is Unix here,
and in Unix we would run it by typing the name of the output program.
Remember what Dennis Ritchie wrote.
You have to figure out where your output went.
So where did my program go when I compiled it?
If we type in LS, which stands for list,
we can see we have two files here,
hello.cpp, the one I created,
and something called a.out.
That is an old name that stands for assembly output.
And so I can run that program by typing in ./a.out.
And of course I have no code inside there,
but in fact that program did something.
What it did was it printed out
or it returned to the operating system an integer.
And you might think, what integer?
Well, in fact, every function, like Java,
if it says it has to return a value,
it has to return a value.
The main function in C++ is a little special though,
because it will return a value if you don't return a value.
The default value it returns is this.
So this is implicitly written in every C++ program,
return zero.
And zero signifies to the operating system
that there was no problem.
Now we might be able to,
I'm going to see if I remember this,
because I don't seem with my video to have any way to pause this,
which is kind of unfortunate.
I'm going to see if I can echo.
Yes, that is echoing the return value
from the last program written.
And notice it returns zero.
So many times you'll see the return zero put in there explicitly.
You don't have to put that in.
So now let's see what we want to do to print out our "Hello, world!"
So if this was Python, we'd use a function called print.
And so I would write print, "Hello, print.
My name is print Inigo Montoyo,"
although I'd use my own name, of course.
This is built into the language.
You don't have to add anything special to do this into Python.
It's part of the Python language itself.
I can have multiple arguments.
I can say print, "Hello, space," or a comma, "My name is," and so forth.
And it would add a new line.
I wouldn't need to have a semicolon after it.
So in Python, it would look like this.
I could write print, "Hello, my name is," and so forth.
So I could put all of those things in there.
It would be built into the language, and I wouldn't need to put a semicolon in it.
Most of you are probably more familiar with Java, however.
And in Java, what we need to do is we use the system.out.print method.
And so that is not part of the language.
It's part of the standard library that comes with Java.
However, it's available to every Java program.
We say it's auto-loaded.
Java automatically loads part of the standard library whenever you run a program.
You can have a single argument.
So in Java, I would have to write that somewhat like this.
I'd have to write system.out.println, "Hello," system.out.println,
"My name is," and so forth.
Now you notice with Java, I've had to add a semicolon at the end.
And I've had to use println instead of print.
If I used the print method, I would have to manually add in a new line or use println.
For C++, we don't use a function.
We don't use a method.
Instead, we use an object and an operator, an insertion operator.
And so this, like Java, is not part of the language.
It's in the library.
Unlike Java, it's not auto-loaded.
Unlike Java, it's in something called a namespace.
So you can have multiple arguments.
You can have multiple operators.
But you do need a semicolon.
If you want a new line, you have to manually add a new line with the new line escape sequence or endl.
So this is how we do it in C++.
Again, that doesn't work for -- this doesn't work for -- we can't put Java inside here.
We're in C++.
So we'd say cl, "Hello."
We manually put in a new line.
"Cout my name is" -- or we could use the endl.
And notice I have multiple arguments.
And for each argument, I need an operator that sends my argument to the output object.
Now, this is called cout, not "cout."
And cout stands for "character output."
So we're going to send this out as characters.
I'm going to put "cout Steven Gilbert" instead of that.
You can put in your own name.
I can also put a new line in the middle of a sentence like that if I want, like I've done before.
And I don't need -- I can put in -- I can put this on multiple lines so you can have multiple arguments.
And that's the end of the sentence.
So notice this is one statement.
I have multiple arguments, multiple operators, and all of them are sending the output to cout.
This is one statement.
The statement ends with the semicolon.
And here is our C++ version of "Hello, world!"
Now, in Python, I said that it was a function called print.
So a function -- C++ has functions.
Function is a named piece of code that may take arguments and returns a value
or may carry out an action.
So square root is a function.
Notice that we pass arguments to it and we get back a value.
We pass arguments to it and we get back a value.
Now notice Python has functions.
C++ has functions.
Java does not really have functions.
Java instead has a method.
In C++ we call these member functions.
Now a function, like square root, is not associated with an object or a class.
A member function or a method is defined in a class,
and a member function takes an implicit or invisible reference to an object as its first argument.
So notice if we had a string named str in Java,
we'd call it by writing str.length.
We wouldn't call it by calling length and passing str to it.
That's because str is invisibly passed as a first argument here inside the function.
It's a parameter called this.
And so we use the same thing in C++.
If we have member functions, we call them by using this dot notation, str.length,
which means call length and pass str as the invisible first argument.
Finally we have operators.
Again, we have these in both Python and we have them in C++.
We do not have them in Java.
And an overloaded operator is simply a function that has a special name.
We call that function not by using function call notation or method call notation,
but operator infix notation.
So when I write cout, arrow, arrow, hello,
what I'm doing is I'm calling a function called operator output or operator arrow, arrow,
and I'm passing the left-hand side of this expression
and the right-hand side of that expression as two arguments.
So if you think of an infix expression, a plus b,
a is the left-hand side, b is the right-hand side, plus is the operator.
This is the left-hand side, cout.
This is the operator and this is the right-hand side.
And those are implemented in C++ by writing a special function called operator
with the name of the operator that's used.
Okay, so let's go on and look.
So let's compile our program again.
Now that I've done that, let me go ahead and do it again
and see if I can get this to print hello.
So I'm going to go g++ hello.cpp
and instead I get a whole bunch of errors.
Notice that it didn't work.
These are all syntax errors.
Notice it gave me some suggested alternatives.
Those usually are meaningless.
And so when you get errors like this,
what you want to do is you want to find the first error and fix that.
Cout was not declared in that scope.
So what does that mean?
What have I forgotten in my code here?
What have I done wrong?
So as I mentioned, input and output, the cout object, the endl object,
are not part of the language.
They are part of the standard C++ library.
Just like system.out is not part of the Java language.
It's part of the Java library.
However, in Java, when you run a program,
it automatically includes part of the library,
what's called the java.lang package,
and that includes string and system.out and so forth.
In C++, that's not true at all.
In C++, it's our job to make sure we include everything that we use.
So we use a library feature by including the header.
And so the header we want to include is named Iostream.
That will insert the declarations and the definitions from the standard
library Iostream header into our code.
We'll see in a few moments how that works.
Now, there are actually more than 70 of these headers in C++11,
and so you're going to need to learn some of them by heart.
Otherwise, you're going to look up by looking up the documentation.
So lines that start with a pound sign are not processed by the main compiler.
They are processed and removed by the preprocessor.
These are called preprocessor directives or preprocessor instructions.
So in this case, the include will be replaced with the actual text of the
header file.
Okay, now I'm not going to do this one right now.
We're going to come back and do that one in a moment.
Okay?
So I want to add in the include.
So I'm going to say include Iostream.
So the Iostream goes in brackets.
You notice how your editor will help you there
and show you the different code.
And we'll come down here with the terminal window.
If you type in control and L, you can clear the whole terminal window.
And so we're going to type in just -- oops, hit the wrong key again -- G++
hello.cpp.
Notice we get some errors that are similar but slightly different,
slightly different, right?
So, again, the first error, CL was not declared in this scope.
But notice the alternative here is slightly different.
It no longer says that we have -- thinks we should put in an enum.
It says, "Oh, you notice in Iostream.61.18, standard CL was declared there.
Did you mean to be using that standard CL?"
And, in fact, we do.
So that is the next step.
We need to look at -- hold on, I'm trying to get my thing over here.
I'm going to look at the preprocessed source code in a second.
So in C++, we have something that there's nothing similar to in Java
except the math class.
So a namespace is a group of related classes and functions.
And the math class in Java is very similar to that.
You know that scanner object in the Java util package?
What you do is you create a scanner.
Scanner in equals new scanner system in.
You use a class to create an object.
With things in the math class, you don't.
Matter of fact, it's impossible for you to create a math object.
Instead, the math class simply acts as a container to contain groups of functions,
static functions they're called in the math class,
like math.square root and math.pal.
So namespaces do the same job in C++.
A namespace groups together similar kinds of functions.
And all of the functions in the standard C++ library are in the namespace called std.
Now because std has bad meanings,
bad -- I can't think of the word I'm thinking of --
we generally pronounce it the standard namespace,
rather than spelling out the words.
So to use the namespace, we can do three things.
First, we can explicitly qualify each object.
Now you can do the same thing in Java.
In Java, instead of writing import Java.util scanner at the top of your program,
you can write Java.util scanner in equals new Java.util scanner.
And you never need to use the import statement.
In other words, you can explicitly qualify each of the names in the class.
And we can do the same thing.
We can explicitly qualify the name of the function.
Here I've done that with square root by saying,
I want to call the square root function that's in the standard namespace.
Now in Java, when we do that, we use a dot.
So Java.util dot scanner.
In C++, if we have the same classes, we'd write Java colon colon util colon colon scanner
to say that the scanner was in the util package, which is in the Java package.
So this is called the scope resolution operator, colon colon.
And it's used when we mean that something exists inside of something else.
So here we're saying the square root exists in the standard namespace.
Many C++ programmers like this style.
It's very, very common.
I know at UCI they do all of their C++ programming using this style.
I think it's a little wordy.
And so there are two options for that.
Just like you can write import Java util dot star or import Java util dot scanner,
we can do something similar by saying at the top, using standard square root.
When I do that, in my code, I only have to use the name square root.
Notice I haven't imported any other name from the standard namespace, just square root.
This is called a using declaration.
Similarly, I can import everything.
I can do the import Java util dot star, all the names inside there.
And so we can use a using directive using namespace standard.
Now, there are certain places where we cannot do this.
But for C++ single file implementation files, this is perfectly legal.
So I'm going to go back to my C++ program, and I'm going to add that statement in.
So using namespace standard.
I'm going to try once more. I'm going to go ahead and erase this code here.
And I'm going to do -- again, every time I clear that, G++ hello.cpp.
Now, the fact that I don't get any error messages here means that it compiled correctly.
I can run it. You remember our output is named a out.
And there you have my output, just like it appears on the screen.
Now, I want to look a little bit more at each of the steps that we just did.
I just typed in G++ hello.cpp.
And as it did that, it happily did all of the steps and didn't save anything to disk.
For our in-class exercise, what I want to do is I want to look at --
I'm going to go and open the in-class exercise, click the link for the starter form,
make a copy of the document in my own Google Drive.
Okay, I want to look at each of these steps in the hello program.
The first step I want to look at is the step for the intermediate code.
And so instead of just saying G++ hello.cpp,
what I'm going to do is I'm going to say G++ -e.
Now, this is called a flag. It's telling the driver, I only want to do part of this.
So I don't know why it's -e.
So I'm going to say hello.cpp.
And then I'm going to do a -o. I know that stands for output.
I'm going to say hello.ii.
So I'm going to save just one part of this.
I'm not going to run the compiler phase. I'm just going to run the preprocessor phase.
Then I'm going to go over here and look, and I'm going to see that I have a new file called hello.ii.
So I'm going to go ahead and open that.
And you'll see that this is the code that was actually inside the iostreams.header.
And you'll see, in fact, that it's about 30,000 lines long.
So I'm going to take a little screenshot of part of that.
And I'm on Windows, so I'm going to do that by holding down my Windows key, Shift and S.
And I'm just going to drag a little thing through that.
And then I'm going to go over to my document here.
And I'm going to paste a screenshot of the fact that I can look at the preprocessed source code.
I can look at the preprocessed source code.
That was the exercise we skipped earlier.
Now, I want to take that preprocessed source code.
So I'm going to type something slightly different than what I have here.
But notice I have another flag here. I have -S.
This is going to do the parsing and the code generation phase.
So let me bring my code over here.
So I'm going to go over here. Actually, I'm going to leave that one open.
I'm going to say g++ -S.
Here I'm not going to say hello.cpp. I'm just going to say hello.ii.
I'm actually going to take this as input, my intermediate code, and I'm going to produce another file.
Now watch the file tree on the left when I do that.
Notice that it produces another file here.
If you open that up, you'll notice that this code, again, is human readable.
We can actually look at the code and see what it says.
But this is code for the processor I'm working on, a 64-bit Windows processor.
So I'm going to take my next screenshot, again, Windows Shift-S.
If you're on the Mac, you'd use the Mac ones to do that.
I'm going to take a picture of some of the code there.
And I'm going to go over to my exercise document.
And I'm going to turn the translation unit into assembly and paste in a screenshot of that.
So we've just converted the preprocessed translation unit into assembly language.
Step three is I'm going to take that assembly language and convert it into machine code.
Again, my driver, G++, is going to run another program.
So I'm going to type in here G++-c.
Now, e and s were uppercase.
This c is lowercase.
I'm going to do hello.s because that's my input.
And it is going to, again, produce another piece of output over here, hello.o.
Try and clink that.
It says it's binary data.
It can't be displayed.
So this has all been human readable.
Now it's binary data.
So we have to run another program to show that binary data.
And so that program is called xxd.
And I'm going to say hello.o.
xxd stands for hex dump.
And this shows us in binary the version of our code.
So these are the instructions in binary.
Now, some of them you can recognize over here showing you the parts that are English and so forth.
And so I'm going to go ahead and shoot a screenshot of that.
Shift-s.
And I'm going to paste that where it wants the next one.
So this is my object code.
Now I want to take that object code.
Let me go back to the slides here.
So that converts our assembly language into object code.
And xxd hello.o lets us see the object code.
Now I want to link that object code with some startup code to produce an executable.
So this I'm going to say g++.
My input is going to be hello.o.
And my output is going to be the executable hello.
Now in Unix we generally don't name the executables exe.
And so I have the object file over here.
I'm going to clear this a little bit.
Control-L.
I'm going to click there so I don't get the weird screen thing showing up.
I'm going to say g++ hello.o.
That's my input.
And my output is going to be hello.
So notice this time I don't have any flag.
I'm just taking the object file as input producing output.
And you notice it produced a new file over there called hello.
Now that's the output of the linker.
That's executable code.
Again, in Unix we usually don't name files with an extension that are executable.
If we look inside the -- if we use the Unix shell and we looked inside the terminal,
we used ls, which is the instruction for displaying things.
Notice we have hello here in green with a star after it,
which means that that is executable.
How do we run the program in Unix?
We run the program in Unix by simply using its name.
We simply use its name.
So we could run this program by simply typing hello.
But in Windows that would work fine.
If we do that, it's going to say, "I'm sorry, hello isn't found."
So we have to type in ./, which means make the current directory part of the executable path.
And so hello.
So there's my program.
So when you see that ./, you're just saying run this program in the current working directory I'm inside.
That's all the ./ in front of it means.
So let me go back to my things.
So we turned it into object code.
So let's look at hello again, by the way, now that I've turned it into object code.
Let's look at xxd hello, not hello.o.
Notice it still looks like object code.
But if we looked at the front of it -- I'm going to go to the very front up here.
Well, actually, if you look through it, you would see a lot of additional stuff that wasn't in the original.
This additional stuff is the library code.
Notice this is from glibcxx3.4, libc2.25.
And so that's where it's getting the cout object from that.
So here's the cout object, which is linked into our code.
So I'm going to take that screenshot, control-F-S.
And I'm going to go in and put that inside there.
And again, we wouldn't have seen this in the object code, which is right here.
And I just ran my program.
I'm going to do it again so I can --
I'm going to shoot a screenshot of that.
And I'm going to go in and paste in my screenshot there.
And finally, I'm going to do one last screenshot here.
I'm going to take a picture of my source code.
Okay, again, Windows-Shift-S.
And I'm going to put that inside there.
Okay, so once you've got that copy, what you'll want to do is go to your exercise.
You will have clicked the start assignment.
On the start assignment, you will then go ahead and submit it by either uploading the file,
or in my case I saved it into Google Drive.
And I actually don't know if this works.
I haven't done it before, so I'm going to try it here.
I'm going to select the file.
And this looks like the one I've just done, doesn't it?
Today, I'm going to add that.
I'm going to attach that.
Okay, that actually looked like kind of a lot of work.
What you can do instead of that is you can do just file, download, download it as PDF or open document.
I usually do PDF.
Then open that.
I actually can't see where that is.
That's in my downloads folder over here.
Copy of LEC01.
You might want to change the name on it, put your name on it, and so forth.
And then you can go up here and you can just do file, upload, upload file, choose file.
Here's my copy of Lecture 1, open, and then submit the assignment.
So either one of those will work fine.
And I get the nice confetti that I have actually attempted it.
You can also do new attempt as much as you want.
Okay, so I want to talk a little bit about different kinds of errors before I finish up here.
So compiler errors are the ones that are discovered during the parsing phase.
So if you try and put the wrong value in a variable, you'll get a type error.
If you forget a semicolon, you forget a closing quote, you put the braces in the wrong place.
You'll get a syntax or a grammar error.
The one that's most difficult for students coming to C++ are declaration errors.
C++ doesn't know your name.
And so you saw that when I used perfectly legal code, but I forgot to include the I/O stream
or I forgot to include using namespace standard.
So these are called declaration errors.
And your code will not compile if you have any of these errors.
Now it's possible that you could have an error, but your code would compile,
but in fact it would not run.
So let me show you another program.
Well, I've still got my sandbox up over here.
I'm going to create another program called temp.cpp.
In here I'm going to put in all the stuff I need, include I/O stream, using namespace standard,
and main, notice I've capitalized main here.
Let's see, hello, and I'll return zero, or I could leave off the return zero.
So all of us realize that this should compile.
So I'm going to do control L, select here.
I'm going to do G++ dash C.
Dash C just means compile it.
So notice I don't get any syntax or compiler time errors at that point.
However, if I try and build this, now you can simply do make temp
and not have to go through all the steps we went through.
So notice I got this set of weird errors.
The bottom error here says linker error, command failed with exit code one.
So here is the part I'm going to explain what this means.
In function underscore start, undefined reference to main.
Well, what is function underscore start?
That is part of what the linker code added as startup code.
And so that is actually the first part of every executable,
and it calls the function named main.
So notice these errors that don't have any -- this one happily says it's a linker error.
Most of them will not say it's a linker error,
but they will be errors that look like this.
Frequently they will refer to LD or something like that.
This sandbox seems to use the Clang toolkit for doing the linking.
Ours will use the G++, which will say LD, and it won't say linker.
So these are linker errors, errors that don't happen at compile time.
You can't find the reference to refer to in the compiled files and so forth.
So missing main, trying to compile a program that requires separate files
and you didn't include one file, you have declared a function,
but you didn't define the function.
All of those are discovered during the linking phase.
Again, the only reason we're pointing this out here is because your compiler will
give you back different kinds of error messages,
and they will not exactly explain what happens.
The third type of error is called undefined behavior.
Java went to great lengths to eliminate undefined behavior,
although in Java you could still have a logic error.
You could have an error where your program produced the wrong output.
In C++ we can have something that runs, might produce the right output,
but it still has undefined error.
Undefined error is you're using a feature in the language that may work
occasionally but only runs accidentally.
So, for instance, using a name without a correct header.
It may work on compiler A, but it won't work on compiler B.
It is an error, even if your compiler will accept it.
It is still an error.
Okay, well that's it for Chapter 1.
I'll see you back next time for Chapter 2.